[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ce dossier sensible
je vais partager mon interprétation avec
les accords d'abraham dont nous avons
parlé récemment le monde se met
progressivement en ordre de marche sur
un profil de paix favorable au
développement économique et incluant
l'iran si les négociations à venir le
permettent
devant cette évolution très positive
joan bryden annoncé qu'ils ne les
remettrait pas en cause en dépit des
changements stratégiques qu'il implique
en particulier au maghreb avec la
reconnaissance de la marocanité du
sahara occidental
la france comme l'europe a été absente
de l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume du
maroc
emmanuel macron le président de la
république a su tisser des liens
particuliers avec les dirigeants
algériens avant même son élection à sa
demande
vous l'avez tous vu benjamin stora vient
de produire un rapport essayant de
trouver un point d'équilibré relationnel
entre nos deux pays pour solder le passé
une france très inquiète par la remontée
rapide de l'immigration et de
l'islamisme et d'algérie dont la classe
politique tente de faire oublier ses
erreurs en accusant de tous les maux et
depuis 60 ans ceux qui l'ont quitté lors
de l'indépendance au delà des opinions
et des positions très idéologique des
uns et des autres dans chaque camp il
faut regarder la réalité en face
l'algérie n'a pas d'histoire propre
n'ayant jamais existé en tant qu'etat
jusqu'à l'indépendance comme le rappelle
bernard lugan dans son livre sur
l'algérie l'histoire à londres son
voisin la tunisie
les pubs les descendants des
carthaginois qui derrière hannibal
firent trembler la rome impériale en
algérie les berbères qui habitaient les
zones montagneuses et furent les
véritables premiers occupants sont
devenus une petite minorité
ils sont les descendants de lorraine de
l'aurès kahena qui se bâtit jusqu'à la
mort contre les arabes omeyyades au
septième siècle quand ces derniers
passèrent par cette région pour aller
s'installer en espagne
l'empiré ottoman après en avoir chassé
les espagnols qui étaient installés à
oran et tlemcen a occupé le pays de 15
cents 15 à 18 cents trente durant cette
période
il a laissé une grande autonomie à son
régent le dès qu'ils contrôlaient son
territoire avec l'aide de janissaires
turc c'est à dire de militaires turcs
il pratiquait la piraterie esclavage des
chrétiens tels le corsaire née en grèce
parce qu'on ne sait pas qui ziercke à
hirel d'hindi barbos qui a la dent un
crs jusqu à hiverner à toulon avec sa
flotte et deviendra plus tard le baie
d'alger enfin à la colonisation turc
succède à celle de la france pendant 130
ans suite à un coup d'éventail du pacha
turc d'alger contre le consul français
pierre de balle c'est donc une erreur de
croire qu'il y a eu une nation est une
histoire algérienne puisque sa première
expression nationale a été la guerre
d'indépendance contre les français de
1954 à 1962 dans laquelle il faut bien
le dire les chefs algériens furent
appuyé par les américains par les russes
et les pays du tiers-monde
ceci explique pourquoi cette guerre et
la période fondatrice aux yeux de ses
dirigeants et de leurs partis politiques
le fln avait que l'algérie mais dans le
souvenir d'une guerre idéalisé dont le
petit nombre des combattants des willaya
de l'intérieur qui ont véritablement et
farouchement combattu la france a été
remplacé par d'autres ceux des armées de
l'extérieur qui n'ont quasiment jamais
livré bataille auxquels se sont rajoutés
une multitude de résistante dernières
heures
leur nombre a proliféré après
l'indépendance comme en france en 1944
après le débarquement et la gestion de
ces anciens combattants coûte fort cher
aux finances publiques algériennes
comment un état détenant autant
d'énergie fossile et bénéficiant de
capacités agricoles et touristiques
prouver peut-il se trouvait dans une
situation économique aussi difficile
faisant partie des principaux pays
producteurs d'hydrocarbures sans pouvoir
en fixer le prix de vente qui dépendent
l'opep
l'algérie est le plus riche de tous les
pays du maghreb est celui qui possède le
plus de potentiel pour construire son
avenir lors des accords d'evian la
france lui a fait un cadeau magnifique
en intégrant les nappes pétrolières dans
les frontières du nouvel état pourtant
les zones concernées faisait partie du
sahara dont le territoire et les
populations n'avaient rien à voir avec
les arabes du nord dont l'implantation
ne dépassez pas saïda et biskra
d'ailleurs pendant toute la guerre
d'indépendance
il ne livrera bataille qu'une seule fois
plus au sud à timimoun malheureusement
cette richesse a été mal utilisée par un
état qui s'est rapidement pénalisée par
la nationalisation des secteurs clés de
l'économie et la mise en place d'un
processus de planification centralisée
il s'est ensuite affaibli malgré le
passage à la démocratie dans les années
80 par la corruption d'une partie des
élites et par le développement de
l'économie informelle
alors certes on a oublié que durant les
dernières années de la colonisation
la progression du produit intérieur brut
en algérie fut médiocre avec une moyenne
annuelle qui était de 0 44% alors que la
france y consacrer un budget bien
supérieur à celui des autres territoires
extérieurs et départements en métropole
les conditions de mise en oeuvre des
accords d'evian ayant provoqué le départ
brutal de l'accumulation françaises et
de leurs partisans
le pib s'est effondré de 33% et il a
fallu six ans
pour retrouver le niveau de vie 1960
à cela il faut ajouter que comme
toujours dans l'histoire
ce jeune état a connu des révolutions de
palais et des prises du pouvoir plus ou
moins violentes qui ont éloigné des
dirigeants talentueux et perturber sa
dynamique de développement comme le
rappelle ahmed bouyacoub dans son livre
cinquante ans après l'indépendance
malgré ses efforts l'algérie n'a connu
qu'une croissance moyenne de 1,40 % sur
cette période de 50 ans contre 2,21 %
maroc et 3,25 pour cent en tunisie et
cela en dépit d'un volume
d'investissement global supérieur de 85
% à celui du maroc et de 28 pour cent de
celui de la tunisie
il est vrai qu'une bonne partie des
fruits de la croissance ont été
consommés par une démographie galopante
avec une population passée en 60 ans
2,11 à 44 millions d'habitants
il ne faut pas oublier également les
terribles conséquences sur le plan
économique de la décennie de guerre
civile religieuse entre 1991 et 2002
avec son niveau de violence qui fut
comparable à la guerre civile
idéologique vécu en espagne durant les
années 30
d'un autre côté ce drame qui a touché
directement de nombreuses familles et
marqué les générations a permis à
l'algérie d'éviter le printemps arabe
qui fait si funeste dans de nombreux
autres pays du sud et de l'est de la
méditerranée
malheureusement après ces années de
braise durant lesquelles les militaires
ont sauvé la démocratie algérienne
le pouvoir s'est révélé incapable de se
remettre en cause ceci explique la
popularité de l'irak
le mouvement de contestation pacifique
hebdomadaire qui réclame dans toute
l'algérie une véritable démocratie et la
participation des citoyens aux affaires
publiques comme le rappelle la rédaction
du monde
dans son livre sur l'état du monde en
on trouve chez les manifestants et leurs
sympathisants
une bonne partie de cette jeunesse ayant
de 15 à 29 ans et représentant 23% de la
population bénéficiant d'un bon niveau
de formation ayant souvent vécu ou
travaillé à l'étranger
cette génération est impatiente de
prendre les rênes du changement et
introduire les réformes nécessaires
malgré la nouvelle constitution de 2016
et les poursuites judiciaires contre les
abus de certaines élites
le pouvoir reste confisquer la récente
élection d'un nouveau président n'a pas
encore produit le changement espéré
alors face à ce constat il est légitime
de se poser la question de la réussite
apparente de son voisin marocain dont le
produit intérieur brut et d'un quart
inférieur à celui de l'algérie et qui ne
possède pas d'énergie fossile
une évidence s'impose la problématique
de ce dernier est totalement différente
car c'est un royaume avec une histoire
millénaire
idriss 1er furent 789 le premier sultan
d'un royaume qui allait de la mauritanie
à la méditerranée et depuis la
continuité du pouvoir central s'est
maintenue en dépit des changements
dynastie jusqu'à celle des alaouites qui
sont venues du tafilalet dont le nom
provient de leur filiation avec ali et
fatima la fille du prophète
le roi actuel mohamed 6 en est le
descendant avec le titre de commandeur
des croyants
ce qui lui donne bien entendu une
légitimité dans tout le monde arabe
le maroc a été un protectorat français
de la signature du traité de fès en 1912
jusqu'à 1956 soit faut pas l'oublier
moins que le temps passé par la pologne
dans l'union soviétique durant ces
quarante deux ans les français ont
imposé leur vision coloniale mais en y
introduisant une dimension humaniste à
l'exemple du maréchal lyautey qui
respecte les institutions et moderniser
les infrastructures comme le rappelle le
monde diplomatique du 20 août 2019 et le
site hérodote j'en donne une explication
détaillée
après son accession au pouvoir en 1927
le sultan mohammed ben youssef n'hésita
pas courageusement à tenir tête aux
résidents généraux successifs envoyé par
la france qui gérait le pays
en liaison directe avec les chefs
berbères des différentes régions en août
1953 à la demande du residence générale
et sans le remplacer les français l'exil
air en corse puis à madagascar et
ceux-ci déclenchent à une prise de
conscience et la renaissance du
mouvement nationaliste qui existait
avant la deuxième guerre mondiale
après trois années troubles protectorat
fut arrêté en 1956 et le sultan
réinstaller à rabat en tant que roi
mohamed 5 comme mandela en afrique du
sud il eu la sagesse de ne pas opposer
dans un esprit de résistance et de
revanche les populations européennes
juive et berbère ce qui a permis
une évolution progressive du royaume
vers son indépendance économique et
politique régnant sur un pays pauvre
son fils le roi hassan ii a tenu le pays
d'une main de fer tandis qu'ils leur et
organisa en privilégiant le
développement des infrastructures et
d'administration civils et militaires
son fils mohamed 6 plus libérale est
conseillé par un groupe de jeunes
dirigeants formés dans les écoles et
universités internationales a su faire
considérablement évolué le royaume tout
en veillant à préserver les équilibres
internes à la société maroc comme
l'avait fait le président bourguiba en
tunisie
il a fait adopter des lois fondamentales
sur la place des femmes dans la société
assurant la stabilité du pays face aux
islamistes il à attirer les
investisseurs étrangers dont ceux de la
péninsule arabique
je vends sur le coup et la qualification
de la main-d'oeuvre
il a créé de grands centres de
développement industriel comme tanger ou
kénitra tout en maintenant la paix
sociale
aujourd'hui malgré une faiblesse
énergétique qui le pénalise par rapport
à son voisin le royaume chérifien est
devenu synonyme de bonne gestion et de
pôles d'attractivité au maghreb
on peut ajouter que le maroc pratique
essentiellement l'islam sunnite malékite
qui est enseigné dans les établissements
scolaires publics et qui prône la
générosité et la tolérance
pourtant le parti majoritaire le parti
de la justice et du développement et
d'idéologie islamistes le roi en a pris
acte et l'a intégrée dans les
gouvernements car ce parti affirme
vouloir contribuer à la construction
d'un maroc moderne et démocratique ou
plan international
en s'appuyant sur l'espagne et la france
le maroc a de bonnes relations avec
l'union européenne tant sur le plan des
échanges économiques
le de l'industrie ou du tourisme mais la
grande réussite du roi et l'afrique où
son pays est devenu le deuxième
investisseur après l'afrique du sud
il est vrai qu'il s'y est impliqué
beaucoup personnellement multipliant les
voyages pour rencontrer les chefs d'état
et développer des relations de
partenariat ayant quitté l'organisation
des états africains en 1984 par suite de
la présence la république sahraouie le
royaume n'a pas pu faire partie de
l'initiative pour le développement
régional de l'afrique
il l'a non compensés par un discours et
des actions très volontariste visant à
développer des rapports bilatéraux
étroits avec des pays amis de l'afrique
francophone
puis en direction de pays anglophones et
enfin des pays hostiles à sa thèse sur
le sahara occidental sont autour en 2017
dans l'organisation de l'union africaine
s'est faite avec le consensus des 55
pays membres en dehors des réserves de
l'algérie l'afrique du sud et l'angola
s'appuyant sur hit mar capital leurs
fonds souverain créé en 2006 les
marocains ont beaucoup investi dans le
développement durable et par le biais
d'accords de coopération dans les
télécoms les assurances et des projets
d'investissements majeurs comme par
exemple gazoduc entre le nigeria et le
manque sur le plan financier
ils sont devenus progressivement le hub
incontournable au niveau du financement
d'opérations économique et industriel en
afrique
et j'ajouterais la base avancée des
financiers du golfe
pour nous il est malheureusement évident
que les marocains ont remplacé les
appeler français en afrique francophone
au niveau des relations commerciales
alors que les espagnols conformément aux
accords internationaux se préparait à
quitter le sahara occidental bleu roi
hassan ii a organisé à partir du 6
novembre 1975
une grande marche pacifique dit marche
verte pour occuper le territoire situé
au sud du maroc le long de la côte
atlantique
il a justifié cette mobilisation d'une
ampleur nationale en rappelant que ce
territoire faisait partie intégrante du
royaume du maroc puisque milan plutôt le
royaume de fès s'étendait jusqu'à
l'actuelle mauritanie quatre mois plus
tard le 26 février 1976 les espagnols
ont commencé à quitter leurs colonies
les troupes marocaines
ils sont rentrés et le front polisario
mouvement armé soutenu par l'algérie a
proclamé la république arabe sahraouie
démocratique et revendiquer la
souveraineté sur le territoire
en 1991 après quinze ans de guerre dans
le désert
les deux parties ont signé un cessez le
feu sous contrôle de l'onu qui prévoyait
un référendum de termine à sion alors
que les sahraouis vivaient dans des
camps de réfugiés en algérie le roi
hassan ii avait dès le début de son
action
jeter les bases d'un plan de
développement de l'ensemble du sahara
occidental qui continue de nos jours en
s'appuyant sur la mise en oeuvre d'une
autonomie régionale dans ce cadre parmi
d'autres investissements lourds
la ville de laâyoune a été agrandi et
modernisé et celle de darla a été
construite plus au sud pour recevoir 100
mille habitants et sédentariser les
nomades autour d'activités agricoles
maritime
la région est très riche sur le plan
maritime et industriels tout ceci n'a
pas empêché bien entendu les violations
répétées de l'accord de 91 et l'échec de
toutes les négociations entre les quatre
entités concernées
le maroc la mauritanie l'algérie et le
front polisario
le front polisario appuyé par l'onu
continue à demander son référendum
tandis que le maroc développe son
concept d'autonomie territoriale
avant d'évoquer la normalisation des
relations entre israël et le maroc sous
l'égide des états unis
rappelons à l'instar de jean michel
bénichou dans son article d'opinion
international du 16 février
un événement que la plupart de nos
concitoyens ignorent mais qui compte
énormément pour les américains le 20
décembre
1777 le sultan de l'époque sidi mohamed
a reconnu officiellement l'indépendance
des etats-unis faisant du maroc premier
pays ayant établi des relations
diplomatiques avec le jeune état
américain en france on a aussi tendance
à oublier le durant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
le sultan mohamed 5 comme le général
franco en espagne a refusé de livrer aux
allemands leurs sujets de confession
juive
l'accord signé à bille qui serait donc
pas une véritable surprise d'autant que
malgré l'accord de 91,6 lié à l'onu le
président américain reconnaît la
souveraineté du maroc sur le sahara
occidental
stratégiquement le concept d'autonomie
du sahara occidental qui dépendrait du
manque est apparu aux américains comme
la seule base réaliste d'un règlement
juste et durable
le président biden a confirmé sa mise en
oeuvre
ayant la conviction partagée avec la
grande majorité des pays africains et du
reste du monde que le conflit du
polisario devient une source de menace
sécuritaire des d'instabilité dans une
zone déjà déstabilisés par le
développement du jihadisme les algériens
évidemment mécontents considère la
décision américaine comme une ingérence
dans un problème interne qui peut mettre
en difficulté leur leadership sur le
maghreb
leur action d'autant plus forte
que le maroc bien qu'au moins riches et
plus petit en surface et en population a
toujours été considérée comme une menace
politique économique et militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france pourrait
jouer un rôle médiateur très utile ou
deux partent d'autres pays a toujours
entretenu des relations amicales avec le
maroc alors qu'elles ont été souvent
orageuses avec l'algérie mais cette fois
ci les choses ont changé le président
emmanuel macron lors d'un de ses
déplacements en algérie a fait
clairement repentance au nom de la
france
en condamnant la période coloniale et
ses excès par ce fait il s'avère être le
mieux placé pour contribuer à la fin
d'un conflit en facilitant ses modalités
de règlement
il a ainsi l'opportunité de contribuer à
normaliser des relations apaisées entre
nos deux partenaires
ce serait d'autant plus utile que ayant
été tenu à l'écart du bouleversement du
moyen-orient la france aurait ainsi
l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifiées ce
serait dans l'intérêt de ces deux pays
amis et de leurs populations mais
également d'une autre qui est
aujourd'hui en première ligne quand un
problème surgit au sud de la
méditerranée à bientôt
[Musique]